content marketing has been around for
over a hundred years but in the online
world customers are behaving in lots of
new ways and they're consuming content
on various kinds and types of devices
that changes things content marketing is
now about creating content that
consumers will engage with and act upon
not just read or listen to or watch so
in this introductory module we're going
to provide you with an understanding of
how content marketing affects the
decision making process when people are
on the customer journey to making a
purchase and with a solid content
marketing strategy your customers buying
decisions can actually happen faster you
can basically shorten the decision
making process and you can reach and
expand to new prospects so one of the
things that we hope that you're going to
learn after basically taking this module
you should be able to do the following
first of all you can define content
marketing and other related concepts
secondly you should be able to explain
why content needs to be relevant and
valuable in order for it to be effective
third you need to describe the overlap
between content marketing SEO social
media marketing fourth you need to name
five traits of effective content
marketers and last but not least you
need to explain the benefits of content
marketing
these are our objectives and hopefully
they're going to be your learning
outcomes so content marketing is not a
new concept it's been around for over a
hundred years in fact one of the classic
foundation stories of you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the Michelin brothers in
France and the Michelin brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay
you know where were pressure right now
we're two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an innovative product at its
time called the automobile in an era
where the roads were horrible in a place
France where frankly people didn't like
to get outside of Paris and into the
provinces because my god what was worth
going out there for you know for Paris
it's all happening here and what the
Michelin brothers realized is if they
wanted to sell more tires they had to
get people to drive farther and farther
and use them so what do they come up
with the concept that really is the
birth of content marketing in my book
was the Michelin Guide and the Michelin
Guide was unique in that it reviewed
restaurants not just restaurants nearby
in Paris but restaurants out there in
the provinces and the Michelin brothers
are the ones who came up with the one
two and three star rating system to say
this restaurant I know it's way out
there it's you know bad roads but guess
what to die for the ratatouille oh you
got to have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way now since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way which
hotels you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to repair and guess
what that put Michelin on the map why
they weren't trying to sell you more
tires they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or an attire repair that I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a featuring
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to their audience about
what their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900 was food
and by creating content the gothy
audience to get into their new
innovative automobile and drive all the
way out there into the provinces for
that absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant people got more flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the way michelin sold
more tires so that that's a great story
every time you sort of you know hit a
pause and like well we're going content
marketing and we need to come up with a
concept I go back to the Michelin Guide
it's it's great foundation hey once you
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simply learned
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing click here